yeah he's third in the american league
in innings pitch which is one of the
reasons why the astros wanted to give
him an extended break of eight days
since his last start yeah i think it's
great they pulled him after four innings
and it was kind of on that same page
where zach was like i think this is a
good idea and they were able to do it
with that bullpen working behind him on
the season you can see that 8-3 record
is very good and that whip number
staying as close to one as he can get it
is a very good sign for the astros
one out of nobody on for shortstop ahmed
rosario
ground ball pass grinky and altuve makes
a great play to throw in time jose
altuve
the indians are taking a look at it
deciding whether they want a challenge
looked like he might have been safe oh
yeah he is safe yes good call and they
want to look at this this will be a
tribe managerial challenge and it is an
infield single for a man rosario no
doubt swing and a miss got him on an off
speed pitch running down and in and
grinky picks up his first strikeout
strands a runner in scoring position
mejia 1-4 with a 7-42
his bugaboo has been the first inning
this year
he did make one start against houston
coming two starts ago he went four plus
innings gave up six runs on five hits
gave up that grand slam to altuve so
hopefully he can settle in
brantley at first one out no score
bottom of the first and here's yuli
the 2-2 to guerrielle and that's hit in
the air pretty well to right center
field racing over is zimmer and he won't
get there and one hops off the fence in
front of the astros bullpen brantley
getting the way from omar lopez around
third and coming home the throw home is
up the line brantley scores curiel
slides in the third safely and the
astros have a one-nothing lead runners
at the corners in one out astros leading
one nothing in the bottom of the first
and now it's correa there's one two
slider did he check his swing he did not
that strike three
big strikeout for
mejia two down in the inning
good pitch got him looking fastball
inside corner inning over a couple of
k's for mejia but the astros grab the
early one-nothing lead
[Music]
robel garcia oh for his last 10.
curveball got him looking on the outside
corner j.c mejia has struck out four in
a row want that slider it's been a good
pitch for him
and he gets another strike yacht five in
a row
whiffed by jc mejia
zach cranky back to the mound in his
third inning of work he'll face the
eight nine and one hitters roberto perez
daniel johnson cesar hernandez
that ball hit pretty high and deep to
left center field long run brantley
giving way mccormick because brantley
calls him off on the warning track
and michael makes the play against his
former team for out number one
granky's first pitch is slug to center
playable mccormick eases back just a few
steps and makes the catch for the second
out zach has done a good job so far
first time through the lineup now facing
the lead-off hitter and cesar hernandez
goes down looking zach has one strikeout
in every inning three in the game one
two three inning for zach who's retired
seven in a row
the astros now with two runners in
scoring position alvarez comes to the
plate the 3-2 is a
smash to first what a play by bobby
bradley and the runners have to hold two
down carlos correa will step in roberto
saying stay right with it he did and he
struck him out again
boy that's some great pitching by
j.c mejia he gets out of a mess here in
the third here's jose ramirez as their
third baseman stocky switch hitter
on the ground yuli has it quickly to
correa for one granky covers he finds
the bag in time
he was searching for it
and he finds the bag and gives a fist
bump to jose ramirez because he could
have been stepped on or tripped him
brand mill race struck out to end the
first inning
got him did he hang it did he bang it
you bet high and deep in god and the
indians tie the game
on nafranimal's 16th home run of the
year
and with one giant swing this game is
tied at one
so two outs runner on second base for
maldonado here's the one one
that's a liner up the middle and that's
a base hit they'll send mccormick and
he'll score easily
bobbling the ball and center with zimmer
but it doesn't matter
it's a 2-1 ball game on the clutch
two-out rbi single by martine maldonado
now jordan will batty has walked it
grounded out
jordan hits one high hits one deep
atwood is way up there second deck shot
jordan alvarez home run number 17
army eyes 57 and 58 to take the team
lead it is now 4-1 astro astros finally
get a mistake from mejia and thankfully
it's jordan alvarez who went into
absolute launch mode
got mejia last time in cleveland on a
line drive this one a little more
majestic and elevated as he got a change
up up in the zone
yanked the third back into my ramirez
and what a throw and a great pick on the
back end by bobby bradley to retire the
side and what a play by ramirez to get
it there great play on both ends the
first and third situation lends itself
to the potential for a
ground ball double play for zach but it
won't be for zach so dusty baker goes
out and gets zach frankie here in the
sixth inning
zach will lead to a nice ovation in a
4-1 lead responsible for the two runners
on brad mel reyes steps in
and he rifles it into left field for a
base hit that'll get a run home and then
on his way to third goes jose ramirez
brad meal into second and they got him
out on he is mad at himself
for being too aggressive in that
situation two outs nobody on for jordan
here's the 2-1
that one's rip
right field down the line and it's off
the top of the wall a banger from
alvarez he's going to go for two after
it was bobbled by johnson and he'll get
there
probably a single and an error but it
almost knocked down the wall here's
correa anybody that plays every day gets
it right see that's a strike wow
and he is oh for his last 26.
and the indians have a one out base
runner and more importantly the tying
run at the plate and it's fran mill
reyes so that means something here's a
one-two
swing and a miss a good splitter to get
reyes and he's down on strikes for the
second out of the inning bradley draws
the walk moving up to second is ramirez
and now harold ramirez will be the
batter here's the pitch swung on line
drive base hit down the right field line
headed for third being waved around is
ramirez he will score into third goes
bradley and harold ramirez comes through
the indians pulled it within one
houston closer ryan presley on in relief
trying to protect a one-run lead is on
for the 37th time
ground ball towards the middle correa
can we'll make the backhand step on the
bag not quite in time carlos
made the play at second which was the
big out and he almost turned a game
ending double play
that would have been a remarkable double
play with him having to move to his
right hit the brakes get back to the bag
indians down to their final out
and ahmed rosario who's three for four
tonight stands in all three of his hits
single swag and amazed presley with 16
consecutive scoreless appearances and
the astros win this opener against the
indians 4-3